[Música]
una nueva revista de prensa esta mañana
de viernes aquí en directo américa de
france 24 vamos a continuar lo que no
pudimos finalizar en el primer bloque
con rosa pérez más de eeuu el día del
libro y porque se celebra mañana 23 de
abril rosa pérez masdéu porque buenos
días de nuevo raúl bien hay bastantes
explicaciones pero empecemos por el
principio esta fecha se remonta a
1926 cuando el escritor y periodista
vicente clavel propuso en españa' que se
estableciera un día como eso no día del
libro y tras algunas deliberaciones se
acabó fijando el 23 de abril como día
pues del libro pero fue en
1995 cuando la unesco estableció esta
fecha como celebración del día
internacional del libro y es que el 23
de abril raúl coincide con la muerte de
william shakespeare con el entierro de
miguel de cervantes y con una muerte
también de otros grandes nombres de la
literatura universal pero yo te traído
el diaria de cataluña porque esta fecha
tiene un simbolismo especial en mi
tierra en cataluña y es que el 23 de
abril es el día de sant jordi o san
jorge en español y es patrón de cataluña
y se tiene constancia de que este día se
celebra desde el siglo 16 pero este día
no solamente se llenan las calles no
solo de barcelona sino también de
ciudades medianas y de pequeños pueblos
de toda cataluña de libros de libros
nuevos de segunda mano de firmas de
autores o de recitales sino que se
llenan también de rosas y es que es
tradición regalar pues a tus personas
queridas una rosa este día pero porque
una rosa y distintas explicaciones pero
yo te voy a contar lo que cuenta la
leyenda y es que la leyenda dice que el
caballero jordi se enfrentó a un dragón
que tenía atormentada la población de un
pueblo de cataluña de montblanc y al
clavarle la espada en el corazón de la
sangre del dragón salió un rosal y de
este rosal las rosas que se regalan cada
23 de abril rosa y cerramos esta nueva
edición de revista de prensa esta mañana
con un tema cultural también lo publica
bloomberg es una cultura popular pero
también un poco cara no y es que
sebastián osorio del medio económico
bloomberg hace una comparativa entre lo
que cuestan las mejores entradas a los
shows del puertorriqueño but banic en su
gira world hottest tour en cada país de
américa latina en relación con lo que
son los salarios mínimos en los
respectivos países y establece que en
argentina son necesarios
0,37 salarios mínimos para comprar la
mejor entrada al concierto the bad bank
y en colombia son necesarios dos o
cuatro salarios mínimos en ecuador 0.6
en méxico 0 075 en panamá 118 y en perú
0 73 hagamos un ejercicio que me encanta
como si tuviéramos todo el dinero del
mundo realmente pagaría una entrada de
estas no no le interesa
no sé raúl es que uno siempre se plantea
qué haría con todo el dinero del mundo
no porque tantas cosas por hacer con
todo el dinero del mundo que no sabemos
si lo gastaríamos pues en un solo
concierto o en otras urgencias pero lo
pero sí le gustaba barbón y si me gusta
bad bone lo disfruto como lo disfrutan
yo creo personas de todas las clases
sociales pero claro el precio de las
entradas ha estado bastante cuestionado
no es así rózsa muchísimas gracias
entonces la dejo este viernes para que
se vaya a disfrutar al ritmo de bat
bonnie y ya suelte las malas energías
destaca de esta semana rosa muchísimas
gracias nos vemos la semana que viene
con más de revistas de prensa y pasamos
ahora a saludar a humaniza en nuestro
último bloque deportivo de esta mañana y
también de la semana rosa
[Música]